If you need some help satisfying your true
crime itch and sifting through all the titles
online, then grab your magnifying glass and
prepare to do some investigating as we look
at the very best true crime movies and documentaries
that Netflix has to offer.
In 2007, while on vacation with her family
in Portugal, three-year-old Madeleine McCann
disappeared from her bed, and has never been
seen or heard from since.
Madeleine's case has resulted in a multitude
of theories and tons of speculation regarding
who was responsible for her kidnapping.
Was it an unknown predator?
Were her parents, Kate and Gerry, to blame?
"I think that the feeling here was, they lied
to us, they were lying to all the world."
There are conspiracy theories galore about
what happened here, and The Disappearance
of Madeleine McCann takes on the enormous
task of examining Madeleine's abduction from
the moment she and her family arrived at their
overseas resort to the ongoing investigation.
Not only does the series offer an in-depth
timeline of events, but it also discusses
the police investigation, Kate and Gerry McCann's
media campaign to find Madeleine, and the
potential theories surrounding the abduction.
Sister Cathy Cesnik was a nun and teacher
at Archbishop Keough High School in Baltimore.
Known for her kindness and dependability,
Cesnik was loved by everyone who knew her.
So when she failed to return home one night
in 1969, it was obvious that something was
wrong.
Tragically, Cesnik's body was found in early
1970, but for years, the nun's case went unsolved.
That all changed in 1992, when a former Keough
student came forward and claimed that Father
Joseph Maskell, the school's chaplain, had
sexually abused her.
From there, authorities dove into Father Maskell's
backstory, uncovering a history of abuse and
a lead in Cesnik's tragic passing.
This twisty tale is documented in The Keepers,
a seven-episode series that dives into Cesnik's
case and the allegations of abuse that occurred
at Archbishop Keough High School.
The series explores the notion that Cesnik's
murder is directly connected to the claims
of abuse, and the show does an excellent job
untangling the various testimonies, timelines,
and theories associated with the homicide.
The Keepers is thoroughly engaging, but it's
also deeply emotional and difficult to stomach.
It's a story of homicide, abuse, and cover-ups.
But most importantly, it's about a community
of survivors coming together to find justice,
both for Sister Cathy Cesnik and for themselves.
Ted Bundy is one of the most well-known serial
killers in American history, thanks to both
his brutal crimes and his bizarre behavior
throughout his trial.
His psychopathic insanity has been captured
for the whole world to see in Conversations
with a Killer: The Ted Bundy Tapes.
"It's hard for me to believe that what I did
is newsworthy."
Released on the 30th anniversary of Bundy's
execution, The Ted Bundy Tapes recounts the
man's life, including his crimes, escape attempts,
and eventual execution via the electric chair.
But what separates The Ted Bundy Tapes from
every other movie and TV show about the killer's
crimes is the never-before-heard audio interviews
with Bundy himself.
"With every murder, leaving a person of this
type hungry.
Unfulfilled."
The Ted Bundy Tapes is a chilling experience
because we know that Bundy is, in fact, responsible
for the crimes of which he was accused.
Hearing him speak as if he'd done nothing
wrong is both an aggravating and horrifying
experience.
"The next time he did it, he would be fulfilled.
And the next time he did it he would be fulfilled.
Or the next time he did it he would be fulfilled."
In each interview, it's clear that Bundy's
manipulative nature is at play, and he's attempting
to sway listeners with every word.
If you're interested in learning how a maniac
charmed so many people, The Ted Bundy Tapes
is definitely worth a watch.
In December 2015, the documentary series Making
a Murderer was released on Netflix, and almost
immediately, it became a massive hit.
It garnered attention from big names like
Ricky Gervais, Alec Baldwin, and Mandy Moore
on social media.
The series even inspired viewers to take action
in the form of online petitions.
But why did this documentary impact so many
people?
The series follows the story of Steven Avery,
a man who served 18 years in prison for the
attempted killing of Penny Beernsten.
With the help of the Innocence Project, Avery
was released in 2003 after DNA evidence proved
that he was not responsible for the crime.
However, two years after his release, Avery
was convicted of killing a second woman named
Teresa Halbach.
So is Avery guilty of either crime, or is
the man getting railroaded by the system?
"They just don't get what happened.
You know, they don't care about the truth."
The first season of the series is mostly interested
in trying to prove Avery's innocence, and
it makes a compelling argument regarding the
handling of his case.
The second season focuses more on Avery's
lawyer as she attempts to prove his innocence
while having to navigate every legal battle
imaginable.
The controversial show is wildly popular,
and if you're wondering why, now is the time
to find out.
In the 1980s, a controversial Indian guru
named Bhagwan Shree Rajneesh founded the religious
movement Rajneeshpuram.
When the community moved to a large piece
of land in Wasco County, Oregon, with the
intent of creating their own city, the neighboring
small town of Antelope decided to fight back.
Not only was there resistance from their neighbors,
but Rajneesh and his followers faced constant
legal battles and media backlash that threatened
their entire community.
It would all lead to the largest bioterrorism
attack in US history, an event documented
in one of Netflix's very best series, Wild
Wild Country.
"Someone is out there, who poisoned an entire
town."
Wild Wild Country gives a voice to Rajneesh's
followers, as well as the residents of Antelope.
By interviewing members on each side of the
conflict, we get an in-depth view of how the
community came to exist, what life was like
for them, and an examination of the prominent
figures involved.
The series paints a vivid picture of the events
that transpired as the community attempted
to create and hold onto their utopian commune,
at any cost.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.